so we're here to talk to you
about
[Applause]
the picture
no sarah i don't know
okay
sarah
went missing um i'll show you some
pictures of
her on the day
sarah went missing um on wednesday
and her parents obviously and her family
are really worried about now
the inquiry that's been conducted so far
those letters can speak to you about it
and to see what you
what you know about saying okay
so
would you like to do you know where
sarah is yeah right
do you have anything about what happened
tonight
i know that um
she went missing up in um london
somewhere um
what about a week ago or so
but just from what i've got on the news
okay have you ever personally met her no
not personally if you had any
interactions with her at all now what
what would i have personal
interactions with her
well
it's very difficult because
i can't go into a lot of the evidence
because obviously
that's not part of what an urgent
interview is okay this interview is just
about trying to find her
because she's been missing for a while
now i'm sat in handcuffs and
noah
so you must have something
to say that i i know
well i said you've been arrested on
suspicion of kid now
and we believe that you've been involved
in her disappearance and taking her away
from her family okay
so we are trying to find her obviously
everybody is very worried about her
she's got you know parents she's got a
you know she's sick
she's got a boyfriend there's a lot of
people that care about them
on the news
and she's missing and our job our
primary job here is to find out and to
try and find a safe and well
okay
now we believe it you know something
about
where she is and that's why we're here
to look for her and to try and find her
and that's why we're talking to you now
is to try and get you to
have a good think about it
um
well
i am
in
financial
um and i've been
lent on by
i don't know who they are
the group the gang whatever
um
and
they told me what i need to go and pick
up girls and get them to them
so
i said
happening
and
it then came through that
they're gonna
harm my
family take them away and they'll use
them instead
um at that point i have no option
to try and find somebody
so i don't um
there's a couple of names
i was told a place to um take her
that's it that's all that is all i know
this group of people
tell me about them i need to find them
tell me everything you
between sort of lemon main stone area
that i her off
um
i still don't know
i i don't know they just
i just
parked my car up and then the van come
up behind me
flashed me and they all jumped out
um and then they took this girl
um they said
they said you've done good
and
i don't know if my family's going to be
at work but
they threatened
they threatened to take my family away
from me
so
at that point
i'm i'm doing what i can to protect my
family that's it so all i know is that
it was a roundabout
we could try there now i could show you
but i
roughly i don't know
lennon maidstone
i drove
from ashford
okay
yeah
there's a roundabout
that breaks up i guess so
this is the first big roundabout
you carry straight over
to maidstone but instead i went round
that roundabout and back up another road
um and at that point that was flashed
pulled over
um
you guys got out
um
opened my door open that door
and pushed me out against the front of
the car
took the girl
drove off that's it they said we'll be
in touch
so i'm here i'm off work with stress
because
i'm here to protect my family i want to
be here 24 7 for my family they come
from my family
i've got nothing myself i've got no
choice
i'll go back through the route with you
in a minute all right but how do they
contact you how did you contact me
i tried to take over one of their cool
girls and rip her off
so she's told them
and
um
they
they've got me
so
how do they know how do they contact you
how is it they've been in contact with
you to make these threats they just they
just tell me be here being here so hotel
burst and danny foxton
could be here okay so i turned up um
i've got no mobile number and they have
got my mobile number they're obviously
outside watching following
uh just
honestly
how they telling you to be there would
be that how is it there to give you
those directions yeah
they'll come outside so they'll be
outside here yeah
and then they'll say well you're going
to be in focus
at this time or you're going to be in
ashford at this time
that's it there's no links no telephone
numbers
i'm completely on my own but at the same
time being threatened
um it had um romanian plates on the on
the van
um
white
like mercedes sprinter-type fan